Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je suis sûr qu'au moins
une fois dans votre vie,
vous êtes retrouvé face
à ce chantier de construction
qui a duré beaucoup plus que prévu.
Et vous vous en êtes plaint.
Et la réalité, c'est qu'en fait,
la construction, c'est un domaine
qui est très sensible aux imprévus
et qui, même avec toute
la rigueur du monde,
inévitablement nous conduit
à des retards importants.
Et moi, étudiant-ingénieur
des Arts et Métiers,
j'avais besoin de changer ça.
J'ai découvert le milieu
de la construction
et l'inévitable dialogue très difficile
qui existe entre les ingénieurs
et les architectes.
Et je me rendais compte que j'avais besoin
de comprendre les logiques
de conception des architectes.
Comment mieux comprendre un
architecte qu'en en devenant un ?
Je suis donc parti
en école d'architecture.
Et en école d'architecture,
j'ai découvert des étudiants
qui étaient frustrés.
Frustrés parce que
ils ont une imagination débordante,
ils pensent à plein de choses :
des formes qui pourraient révolutionner
notre manière d'habiter dans l'espace.
Et en réalité,
ils ne peuvent pas les construire
parce que ça coûte trop cher.
Donc aujourd'hui,
quand on se promène dans la rue,
on est face à ça :
des bâtiments qui nous entourent
qui sont tous droits,
qui sont simples, standards,
et en fait,
il y a très peu d'œuvres architecturales
complexes, comme celle-ci,
qui sont la raison pour laquelle
les étudiants ont envie d'intégrer
une école d'architecture.
Et quand on voit la complexité
pour construire en béton
des formes avec de la courbure
comme on voyait précédemment,
il faut de la main-d'œuvre
extrêmement qualifiée,
il faut de la précision
et beaucoup de temps.
Bref, ça coûte très cher.
Donc il y a aujourd'hui un fossé
entre la plupart des architectes qui sont
contraints par un budget plus réduit
et d'autres sans limitations financières
qui peuvent produire toutes leurs envies.
Seulement, aujourd'hui,
ça, c'est en train de changer.
Et pourquoi ?
Parce qu'on a des nouvelles
technologies numériques
qui sont suffisamment matures
pour permettre de construire mieux,
de construire différemment.
Vous n'êtes probablement pas sans savoir
que les architectes n'utilisent
plus de tables à dessin,
on utilise un ordinateur.
Avec lui, on ne change pas radicalement
notre manière de concevoir l'architecture,
on continue à tracer des traits,
seulement, c'est sur un ordinateur.
L'intérêt du numérique là-dedans,
c'est de repenser notre manière
de concevoir et
de fabriquer l'architecture.
Donc fabriquer par exemple
avec l'aide de robots.
Des robots qui vont être
extrêmement précis,
répétables,
qui vont être capables de travailler
dans des conditions extrêmes
et avec une cadence qu'un humain
ne pourrait pas reproduire.
Au niveau de la conception,
ça nous pose la question : « Que fait-on
véritablement quand on conçoit ? »
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on conçoit ?
En fait, on a des envies,
on a des contraintes,
on a un certain nombre de
critères derrière notre cerveau
qui nous poussent à créer des formes.
En réalité,
un ordinateur est assez intelligent pour
reproduire le fonctionnement du cerveau.
Donc en réalité, on pourrait
remplacer le fonctionnement
de notre cerveau
par un algorithme qui traduit directement
ces règles en formes.
Donc par exemple,
je veux dessiner un appartement
où ma cuisine soit à côté de mon salon,
où ma chambre soit suffisamment
éclairée et suffisamment grande,
mais un peu à l'écart, etc.
Et c'est un ordinateur qui vient lui-même
pré-organiser ces pièces.
Parmi ces technologies numériques,
il y a notamment l'impression 3D
qui, je pense,
peut répondre à certaines
de mes questions,
aussi bien d'un point de vue ingénieur
qu'architecte.
Qu'est-ce que l'impression 3D ?
C'est ce qu'on fait
dans ces petites boîtes
où on part d'une bobine de fil plastique
qu'on vient chauffer pour assembler
des couches les unes après les autres
et former à peu près toutes nos envies.
Aujourd'hui, ça s'est
extrêmement démocratisé
et on peut construire
à peu près n'importe quoi.
Et là, on se dit :
« Très bien, je vais pouvoir faire
ça pour des bâtiments. »
Et la plupart des gens
ne voient pas les changements
qu'il y a quand on change d'échelle.
Et c'est d'ailleurs assez drôle de voir
que quand on explique qu'on fait
de l'impression 3D dans la construction,
les gens nous disent : « Mais elle
ressemble à quoi, votre imprimante ? »
Et on se rend compte qu'ils
imaginent une grosse boîte
qui va englober tout un immeuble.
En réalité,
qu'est-ce qu'on entend
par « impression 3D » ?
L'impression 3D, ou son autre nom,
la fabrication additive,
ça s'oppose à la fabrication soustractive.
Ça s'oppose à ça.
Ça, c'est créer une forme
en partant d'un bloc de matière
dont on vient enlever de la matière.
Donc pour passer de ce bloc
à la forme voulue,
on a un certain nombre de pertes.
En fabrication additive,
on a 100% du matériau au départ
qui va servir à former notre objet.
Si on appelle ça impression 3D,
c'est juste par analogie avec les
imprimantes 2D qu'on connaît - papier -
où on procède à une création d'image
par division de petits éléments de couleur
qu'on appelle des pixels.
En impression 3D,
on vient découper une structure
en petites quantités de matières
qu'on appellera là des voxels.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans
une imprimante 3D ?
Ce qu'il y a,
c'est une buse.
Une buse qui va avoir pour fonction
de faire passer de la matière
et un robot dont on va pouvoir
contrôler le déplacement
et qui va venir déplacer
cette buse dans l'espace.
Qu'est-ce qui est difficile là-dedans ?
C'est d'avoir en amont de la buse
un matériau suffisamment liquide
pour qu'on puisse le pomper
et l'amener à la buse
et en même temps en sortie de buse,
avoir un matériau qui là ne
s'affaisse pas complètement -
qui doit se tenir lui-même,
mais en même temps pas trop
pour pouvoir avoir une certaine
cohésion avec les couches adjacentes.
Comment on fait en plastique ?
Tout simplement, on fait chauffer
le plastique pour qu'il soit pompé
et ensuite on le refroidit.
En béton,
on vient changer la composition du béton
au cours du procédé.
Alors là, vous me direz :
« Oui mais la construction
en béton, ça a toujours été additif. »
Et de fait,
quand traditionnellement on manipule
du béton, on le coule dans un moule.
Il n'y a pas vraiment de grosse différence
entre le coulage et l'impression,
si ce n'est que, dans un cas,
le matériau doit se tenir à la sortie
et dans l'autre, pas du tout.
En réalité, dans le coulage,
ce qui est important,
c'est l'opération soustractive qui a lieu
dans la création du moule.
Donc c'est assez indirect.
Le moule, pour qu'il soit
considéré comme rentable,
il doit permettre de faire
un certain nombre de pièces,
sinon il est beaucoup trop cher
de faire un moule pour une seule pièce.
Et tout ça, ça a poussé à la
standardisation de l'architecture,
et,
du coup à diminuer la valeur
architecturale qui est produite
et augmenter les consommations
de matières.
Avec l'impression 3D,
on vient de citer un avantage
qui est comme
dans l'impression 3D, c'est du
coulage avec un moule virtuel,
ça ne coûte pas plus cher de faire
une forme différente.
Donc on peut créer de la complexité
formelle gratuite, sans surcoût,
et plus rapidement.
Le deuxième avantage,
c'est qu'on est capable de réduire
drastiquement les quantités de matières,
puisqu'on met la matière qu'on veut
à l'endroit où on veut qu'elle soit
et en quantité suffisante.
Alors qu'aujourd'hui,
la plus grande partie du béton
qu'on utilise est inutile
et on le fait juste
car ça coûte moins cher
avec les procédés qu'on utilise.
Le troisième avantage,
qui est peut-être moins direct,
c'est la sécurité.
C'est-à-dire que
il est beaucoup plus facile
d'envoyer un robot
reconstruire dans des zones
post catastrophe naturelle
plutôt qu'un humain.
Dans toutes les zones risquées,
on va préférer envoyer un robot
qui va travailler à notre place.
Où en est-on ?
Vous avez probablement entendu parler
des maisons construites en Chine,
en Russie, très rapidement.
Ces maisons, elles sont
pour la plupart en 2D et demi.
Ce qu'on appelle 2D et demi,
c'est qu'elles n'exploitent pas
véritablement la 3D :
c'est un plan 2D qui peut
être un peu compliqué
mais ensuite il est extrudé,
droit, verticalement.
Donc si on coupe le bâtiment,
on a le même dessin en 2D.
Et c'est assez dommage, parce
que la 3D nous permet d'exploiter
des formes beaucoup plus intéressantes.
Quoi qu'il en soit en France,
pour voir apparaître
ce genre de structures,
ça va prendre un peu de temps,
et ce, à cause de la certification,
puisque,
pour pouvoir construire en hauteur
dans des endroits accueillant du public,
on doit s'assurer que
ce public est en sécurité.
Pour l'instant, comme on n'est pas capable
de caractériser le matériau qu'on imprime,
puisque le procédé est très nouveau,
aucun bureau de contrôle ne pourra
se porter garant de la sécurité du public.
Donc nous, ce qu'on a fait, avec XtreeE,
c'est qu'on a considéré
qu'on allait couler -
qu'on allait imprimer l'enveloppe
et qu'on allait couler à l'intérieur
parce que le matériau
qu'on coule à l'intérieur,
lui, on est capable de le
calculer et de le certifier.
C'est comme ça qu'on a fait
un poteau de 4 mètres de haut
à Aix-en-Provence pour un marché public.
À gauche, on a le résultat
de ce qu'on a imprimé,
et puis quand on a eu coupé les
supports entre les différentes veines,
il nous reste ce qu'on a
assemblé sur site,
avec à l'intérieur un matériau qui est
coulé, comme sur l'image précédente.
En réalité, c'est uniquement
ce qui est à l'intérieur
qui est utile pour tenir
l'auvent au-dessus
et le reste n'est que du parement.
C'est aussi comme ça
qu'on a développé des prémurs.
Derrière ce nom un peu ennuyeux de prémur,
il y a l'idée d'avoir un mur
tout prêt hyper fonctionnel
qu'on vient mettre sur un chantier.
Et donc
il y a des zones où vous
voyez les veines extérieures,
qui vont venir accueillir
un matériau qui va permettre de
supporter les étages supérieurs.
Le mur est creux
et va permettre,
lorsqu'on y coulera une mousse isolante,
de réduire les pertes de chaleur
et les bruits qui se transmettent.
On est aussi capable de prévoir les gaines
pour tuyaux, les gaines électriques, etc.,
du mobilier à l'intérieur,
et des envies esthétiques
sur les parois des murs.
En réalité, il y a
deux marchés aujourd'hui
qui se distinguent
et qu'on a tendance à comparer :
c'est le marché de l'impression
très rapide et pas chère,
et le marché de l'impression
de formes complexes
où on va avoir besoin de précision
et de qualité.
Pour la première, l'enjeu, ça va être
d'aider à construire dans des pays
sous-développés avec des matériaux locaux,
écologiques.
Pour le deuxième, l'enjeu va être double :
être capable de construire mieux
ce qu'on est capable
de construire aujourd'hui,
donc en apportant de la complexité,
en faisant que ce soit moins cher,
ou que ce soit plus sécurisé,
mais aussi
toute une partie qu'on a
du mal à imaginer aujourd'hui
qui est de penser à des nouvelles formes
qu'on a du mal à penser aujourd'hui.
J'aimerais conclure cette présentation
avec cette citation de Marshall McLuhan
qui, déjà dans les années 60,
prévoyait qu'on serait capable d'ajouter
de la complexité sans surcoût.
C'est la voie qu'a choisie XtreeE pour
révolutionner la construction en béton.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)